ja das große problem bei uns und das
aber auch schon seit da kennen wir schon
seit 30 jahren ist dass die kinder keine
lobby haben und
dass viele dass wir seit jahrzehnten
so immer zeug hat wenigstens drei
millionen kinder unter der armutsgrenze
haben den oder armutsgrenze leben und
ich habe situationen erlebt als
botschafter für das kinderhilfswerk und
für andere organisationen dass kinder
uns das brot aus den händen gerissen
haben vor hunger aber
die kinder verhungern ja nicht nur
weil sie nichts zu essen bekommen die
verhungern ja auch geistig also die
haben die eltern sind überfordert die
eltern teilweise
alkoholiker kümmert sich überhaupt nicht
um die kinder die kinder kriegen keine
werte vermittelt die kinder sind
außenseiter in der schule wir leben
heute in einer zeit wenn man nicht die
richtigen outfits an hat nicht in der
richtigen
winter richtige clique ist dann ist man
sowieso verloren dann ist man
außenseiter und diese kinder keiner
keiner ist da der in irgendwelche werte
beibringen kann die sind solche aufsicht
gestellt und diese kinder sind
teilweise hoch intelligent aber diesen
verloren die trifft viele treffen von
denen ab und ja was was wollen wir für
eine zukunft kreieren wenn wir uns um
die kinder nicht kümmern werden wir wenn
wir
keine werte mehr vermitteln und das
versuche ich seit 30 jahren versuche ich
das also kämpfe ich und dafür und mache
dinge ich habe eine große gala
inszeniert vor vielen jahren das
deutsche kinderhilfswerk und hatte da
dann freunde von mir
bonnie tyler berichtete nielsen angelika
milster sind kostenlos aufgetreten da
hatten wir dann ich weiß wir haben frau
merkel angeschrieben wir hatten frau
fand allein damals als
familienministerin deshalb romy gala
unterschreiben sie formelle lange regale
charity gala und die hatten alle keine
zeit und die frau fand allein wollte
nicht fotografiert werden mit ranzen und
frau kyla weil die so groß sein und dann
die sie so klein auf dem foto und solche
sachen und das schlimme ist
der lok dann hat das alles jetzt noch
vor kraft und ich sehe
da eine katastrophe auf ihn zukommen
weil wir wer es gibt keine werte mehr es
gibt auch der diese diese kinder haben
keinen kein halt man muss auch
organisationen unterstützen es ist ja
alles geld da es ist ja alles gelder
aber seit 20 30 jahren nicht für diese
kinder muss organisationen unterstützen
die sich dieser kinder annehmen die den
eine möglichkeit bieten von zuhause ich
komme selbst aus einem elternhaus das
schrecklich war der vater ein schläger
die kinder die haben zu hause horror die
die sind ausgegrenzt in der schule die
haben die am hunger dann kommen sie auf
die schiefe bahn vielleicht auch das
wohl wenn wundert's ja und dann gibt es
vereine die die
bieten den möglichkeiten dass sie
nachmittags hinkommt sie essen bekommen
dass sie ihre schulaufgaben machen
können das waren lockt dann auch alles
geschlossen war auch dann alles wieder
erledigt alles weg dieser tag hat sie
ihre eigene kindheit geprägt dass ich
mich so sehr für die kinder engagierte
ja ich habe das große glück haben da
muss ich kurz ja danken dass ich ein
extrem starke persönlichkeit bin und ich
möchte dann
trotz dieser meine kindheit war
kriegszustand also ich kann mich nicht
eine sekunde hin solange ich versuche
darüber nachzudenken daran erinnern dass
ich als kind nicht angst hatte ob meine
mutter blutend am boden liegt oder oder
tot ist oder noch lebt der vater mit
spalter hinter ihr her und ich habe mich
mit sechs jahren ausgeklinkt dachte ich
nee also so geht das nicht du musst für
bessere welt kreieren der andere welt
kreieren abgeschlossenen motto prinz zu
werden
beschlossen alte frau zu einer
prinzessin zu machen das leben sollte
schön sein natürlich habe ich da nicht
ein mode verkaufen gedacht hab mich aber
gleich rangemacht filme angeschaut und
das ist heute aus mir geworden ich bin
einfach schöner dass ich versuche die
welt schöner zu machen wird aber immer
schwieriger ja ich kann es inzwischen
nur noch mal in dem ich schön strahle
und viele andere das sehen und daran
sich erfreut und offensichtlich gelingt
es mir ja dass ich ganz viele junge
menschen inspirieren denn die sprechen
mich an da kommen 87 jährige kinder und
sagen ich finde es toll und es ist so
klatte und und auch ja und dass man sie
uns noch verstärkt da machen auch die
gleiche ja ich möchte nein ich habe
jetzt auch wieder das gefühl dass jetzt
mittal mit dem alten lockdown mit krieg
mit allem was wir haben die kinder jetzt
wieder völlig jetzt fahren sie wieder
völlig und das raster da kümmert sich
gar keine ja aber bitte wenn wir jetzt
nicht starten unsere kinder unsere
kindern chancen zu geben was werden wir
für eine gesellschaft was sind das für
eine gesellschaft in 20 frage will ich
gerne meinen bruder geben was sind für
für eine gesellschaft was werden wir für
eine gesellschaft in 20 jahren wir sind
eine wohlstands verwahrlost der
gesellschaft und deswegen stimme ich mit
mir nur zum teil überein es sind
natürlich nicht die kinder schulter
sowie sind wie sie sind wir haben in der
bundesrepublik über 150 familien
hilfsmaßnahmen am geld mangelt es nicht
ganz im gegenteil geld wir millionen
weise ausgeschüttet was schlecht läuft
das überhaupt nicht läuft es gibt kaum
noch eine verantwortung der eltern weil
sich irgendwie alle darauf geeinigt
haben der staat wird das richten und der
stadt kann es nicht er sollte es auch
nicht und ich bitte sie elternschaft ist
eine sehr persönliche angelegenheit
ich bin dagegen persönliche
angelegenheiten zu verstaatlichen oder
zu vergesellschaften wenn die leute
keine verantwortung haben dann
entschuldigung bitte sollen sich keine
kinder kriegen also dingen mangelt es
nicht an geld also herr brunner hat
gerade gesagt am geldmangels nicht woran
mangelt dann dass die kinder haben und
weiter steigt also eher wo das recht es
gibt ein unfassbar riesigen strauß an
familienpolitischen leistungen die sind
teilweise aber so kompliziert also ich
nehme alle einmal nur
die leistung die wohl von denen nur 30
prozent der kinder die überhaupt ein
anspruch darauf haben profitieren davon
da ist so kompliziert ist und so
unbekannt das ist einfach nicht in
anderen jugend in diesem land ist alles
kompliziert dass
am ende die die wissen wie sie sich
durch diesen antrag dschungel
durchforsten die können da einigermaßen
gut von leben andere gehen komplett den
bach runter und klar natürlich haben
familie und eltern eine große
verantwortung und das kann man auch gar
nicht oft genug betonen allerdings das
thema bildung ist eine staatliche
aufgabe und da hat der staat schon eine
riesengroße verantwortung der kommt er
aber reste der journalisten gezielt was
müsste der staat tun damit weniger
kinder in armut lebe jetzt meinen
letzten zwei jahre anguckt dann müsste
man unterricht erst mal stattfinden
lassen das wäre schon mal die erste
voraussetzung ist das ist ja schon nicht
passiert so dass wir einfach die
situation haben wir ja klöckner
beschreibt das wie einfach die
den einfluss aus dem elternhaus auf ein
späteres leben oft ein erfolg in der
bildung also und damit auch auf den auf
die möglichkeit etwas aus dem leben zu
machen die träume zu verwirklichen sie
hatten einen traum sie konnten ihn
verwirklichen das kann ich aber oft nur
wenn ich auch eine gewisse bildung haben
abschlüsse da sind wenn ich eine
ausbildung studium machen kein gegenpol
zu dem
zu hause wo gar nicht stattfindet ein
gegenpol das überhaupt sehe es gibt auch
andere möglichkeiten
oder es gibt auch ein anderes es gibt
auch andere
andere eltern andere familien und andere
herangehensweisen ich vergesse nicht ich
habe oft gefragt wenn ich dann da war
ein paar hundert kinder und das heißt
was willst du werden und dann sagt ihr
eigentlich möchte prinzessin werden seit
du kannst eine werden ich wollte auch
ein mode prinz werden ich bin auch einer
geworden und ich was mir gelungen ist
ich habe so fünf sechs mal haben wir
junge menschen geschrieben die durch
mich aus wirklich schwierigen
verhältnissen und schon am abdriften
warnt die kurve gekriegt haben einen
beruf erlernt haben und sich das nie
getraut hätten weil sie gedacht haben
ich bin ein looser ich kann das nicht
spaß an den direkten zusammenarbeit mit
kindern etwas habe ich ja gemacht über
jahre erzählt habe ich direkt ja immer
wir sind ja das sind ja auch mit dem
deutschen film sollte immer an
brennpunkte gegangen ja deshalb sieht
man ja eigentlich sieht man dann ja auch
was los ist und dann kommt natürlich
immer das argument sagt wird aber die
eltern kriegen ja geld aber die t
verkaufen das sage ich ja aber dass wir
müssen erstmal dem kind helfen das ist
ja mal völlig unwesentlich was das
elternteil macht aber wenn wir jetzt ich
möchte das noch mal sagen wenn es jetzt
einrichtungen gibt wo die kinder hin
können wenn sie dass sie endlich mal von
zu hause auch rauskommen dass sie ein
ein ort überhaupt haben wo sie hin
können nicht irgendwo auf der straße
herumlungern wo es nur noch kriminell
dann ja dann hat man sich locker als
auch die hat man auch alle geschlossen
und jetzt ist es so dass vieles auch gar
nicht mehr gar nicht mehr geöffnet wird
hat dass die leute auch nicht mehr
bereit sind das funktioniert der autor
mit mit ehrenamtlichen helfern zum
größten teil und da finde ich da müsste
auch ein psychologe mit trend seien da
müsste auch möchte auch eine lehrkraft
seiner millionen von psychologen
pädagogen dran es sind nicht zu weniger
leute in der kinderversorgung tätig
sondern zu viel und bei allem respekt
für ihre leistungen das was die eltern
versäumen kann der staat nicht
ausgleichen nein aber man ruft nach mehr
stadt äußerst suspekt am ende kriegen
dann kleine zombies die sich in sich ein
jugendlicher hat auch gerne mehr start
aber das ist nur einen haken also wenn
wir das noch mal den mit dem kind wenn
ich bin auch kinderlachen botschafter
und wir kriegen auch mit wie schwierig
sein geld ranzukommen ist wenn etwas
privat jedes siebte kind hat eben auch
kein bett in deutschland wie heute
glücklicher sagt nur der punkt ist der
total arbeitet die eltern form ich
wollte auch meine kinder nicht von
lehrern erziehen lassen nur mal in die
schule schauen wo es anfängt also wenn
wir auch über eltern sprechen müssen wir
da ja schon hingehen in der pandemie
wird zugemacht haben 30 prozent mehr
häusliche gewalt gehabt und auch viel
schlimmere dinge mit kindern der zweite
punkt ist versuchen sie mein digitales
buch für zu hause zu bekommen gab es ja
gar nicht das heißt dann fangen wir dann
auch mal an in der schule andere themen
bei zu lassen wenn der glückler kein
weder grundstudium hat oder so wie ich
motivation treten an der schule wird gar
nicht zugelassen und eine freundin von
mir macht tatsächlich lehrerseminar und
ich war schockiert wie sind wir sagte
die erste frage die sich stellt wie
denken sie über kinder ich habe erst
gedacht die frage stellt warum lehrer
nicht doch weil viele lehrer auch ein
schlechtes bild von kindern haben weil
ihm schlecht erzogen sind weil die
keinen respekt mehr haben und deswegen
natürlich schon zu hause auch an aber
wir müssen ganz andere fächer in der
schule wie persönlichkeitsentwicklung
wie man lerne ich denn mal was eine gmbh
ist oder mich selbstständig machen wie
komme ich denn überhaupt dann solche
ideen wie ein glück war das kann ich
heute nur bei instagram aber also ich
war komplett falsches bild worüber bei
anderen seite gibt es ja auch helikopter
eltern also wir sehen ja auch das
phänomen dass kinder wirklich fast über
überwacht total rasenmäher eltern oder
helikopter eltern einen wechsel frei
gemäht absolut kinder kennen ja keine in
anführungsstrichen im mittelstand noch
mal keine not wert als alles da die
fahren den urlaub der kühlschrank ist
voll ihr studium wird meistens
finanziert die haben keine extra jobs
mehr da geht keiner mehr da man den
rasen mähen und da müssen wir wieder
ansetzen werte wieder schaffen denn
nochmal die dies im moment machen sind
viel zu klein wenn wir die unternehmer
nämlich den mittelstand den motor ja
noch mehr besteuern kann ich verstehen
dass die heute darüber nachdenken
auszuwandern weil du sollst den letzten
zehn jahren
wir bleiben bei den kindern aber auch
ganz viele die nicht in urlaub fahren
und sie sondern die irgendwo in einer
ein zimmer wohnung lebt aggressiven
vater der die bude kurz und klein schlag
der stehen die alkoholisiert ist das
kind gefällt auch ein paar es ist
ständig terror zu hause und gar keine
möglichkeit hat irgendwo raus zu kommen
und aus dieser kiste gar nicht aus um
panische angst hat also da ist nicht die
frage mit den urlaub fahren die damen
wieder den start der überregulierten die
behörden nicht helfen punkte wie wäre es
damit den eltern die kinder zu entziehen
offenbar ist die größte gefährdung
stelle für kinder der das eigene
elternhaus was ich aber es stimmt beim
missbrauchs geschichten bei verletzungen
durch prügel elternhaus eine ganz
gefährliche sache eher gehen sie um
mitternacht durch kreuzberg spazieren
als ich in der eigenen vater zu
unterhalten da habe ich in eine
persönliche frage stellen vielleicht
auch noch mal zu kennzeichnen und den
kindern wenn man selber eine schwere
kindheit wie sie auch erlebt hat kann
man das jemals komplett verarbeitet oder
blieb es ein eigentlich für immer
also man muss irgendwann deckel drauf
man aber so 100 prozent verarbeiten kann
man nicht das drama ist je länger man
darüber nachdenkt desto eher
desillusioniert da sagt man ich habe am
anfang nur
bedienen und mit meinem vater und
irgendwann habe ich dann festgeschrieben
meine mutter hat auch mit schuld daran
und dann fehlt mir irgendwann ein habe
ich so dass durchgeschaut und dann haben
wir ein foto von einem bekannten der
familie in die hände dafür ein dass die
habe ich mit sechs jahren sexuell
belästigt hat das hat sich völlig
verdrängt also irgendwann muss man
deckel drauf machen weil das wird immer
noch schlimmer sind es wird nicht besser
und da waren so viele punkte ich bin nur
sehr dankbar und ich danke gott dass ich
diese stärke hatte und diese kraft die
haben ja nicht alle und dass ich eben
nicht abgedriftet bin und sondern dass
ich gesagt habe nicht an kreiere ich mir
eben nimmt die eigene welt dann lass die
mal machen ich mache ich habe damit
nichts zu tun ich bin irgendwelchen
falschen film ich mache meine eigene
welt und dann bin ich aber auch wieder
auf das unverständnis gestoßen der
gesellschaft wenn ein junger mann rum
läuft wird sich da anzieht wie ein prinz
wähler dann wird auch wieder gelacht und
und und als ich dann begonnen habe meine
shows zu machen wird auch über mich
gelacht und schwul und gelacht und wie
läuft herum und isst ja ja und jetzt
wenn jetzt kommen sie alle und sagen ich
fand sie immer schon tollen das war ja
das kann ich mir denken ja ich finde
toll dass sie die stärke und auch die
erfahrungen der kinder selbst in das
engagement für kinder steigt und die
kinder finden toll dass ich wenn sie
gefragt werden was finden sie toll dann
sagen sie ich finde toll dass sein ding
macht der lebt sein leben wir bock hat
in der tasche gehabt dass andere gut
finden und so möchte ich auch leben